welcome to their technology tuesday on
friday i am off to Walt Disney World's
for my annual family trip and I recently
discovered an awesome new website and
app called touring plans that is going
to save me hours of planning and also
shave off hours of waiting in line so
it's a website and an app I'm going to
hop over to my computer because I want
to share it with you so this is what the
Turing planes calm dashboard looks like
and the first thing I did was enter in
my information as to when I was going to
be arriving so I'm going to be going
from march twenty second until march
twenty seventh the first thing that I
loved about this was that it would tell
me how busy each of the parks were on
you tune two different days it starts
out by telling you the weather and then
also telling you how busy in general
while Disney World crowds are from a
seven of here 7 7 9 99 and then what it
lets you do is select the parks so you
can figure out which part is best to see
on which day so that they had arrived as
a Sunday I was worried that be really
busy I click on select parks and it
shows me that magic kingdom is a seven
Epcot is at eight Hollywood souza seven
and animal kingdom is a nine so you know
if I'm planning this out I want to avoid
animal kingdom and go to magic kingdom
so I picked that one to start I did that
for every day what I discovered was that
Wednesday was actually one of the
busiest days at least March 25th is for
some reason and so I'm actually going to
be avoiding the park on that day I have
a five-day plan and six days to do it so
I thought it'd be skipping out on either
that first Sunday or the last Friday but
as it turns out this Wednesday is the
busiest day of all so if I click on
select parks everything is a nine out of
ten nine out of ten nine out of ten nine
out of ten nine out of ten so right
there by avoiding Disney World on that
wednesday i'm gonna be saving a lot of
time and frustration standing in line
the next thing that lets you do is
create a touring plant basically you can
figure out what you're going to do on
each day in each park so in the first
day i'm going to magic kingdom day 1 i'm
going to load both my itinerary as well
as all of the attractions so I can see
what
up so this is a list of all the
attractions and it tells you how it
ranks for different age groups my son is
five years old so I'm going to be
looking in this area to see how well
some of the rides rank of course going
to be concerned about is this
entertaining for him is it going to be
scary for him is it going to be tall
enough to go and this quick website
shows me all the information that I need
next and move into my customized plan I
can add all of the different things that
I want to see on that first day there's
a tool here at the bonus has a
detraction I can click on that it knows
that i want to go to Walt Disney World
Magic Kingdom and it'll show me all the
different options that i can add to it i
would just have to click any one and
then click Save once you've added in all
the attractions you want to see you can
then click optimize and it'll tell you
what order you should go see all the
events in so for my first day I'm going
to rush to the Seven Dwarfs Mine Train
where I'm still going to wait 39 minutes
in line but then jump to Winnie the Pooh
Barnstormer done with the flying
elephant and continue on with my day
they give you the option about how fast
you walk and how much time you want
spent between waiting and walking that
will help you pick the most customized
version for your day you can also add in
meals or break so that you're not just
going from an attraction to attractions
to attraction and burning out so for all
of my days I added in a lunch at twelve
o'clock to rest and that gives me 60
minutes to have lunch and wander around
finally what I did was booked my fast
passes with your tickets Disney allows
you to book fast passes so you can skip
the line and get right to the front I
basically looked at my touring plans
optimize plan and looked at what had the
longest wait time and then I went to
book a fast pass for it now
unfortunately the Seven Dwarves my train
fast passes were all sold out but I
managed to get them for under the sea
The Little Mermaid Peter Pan's flight
and Buzz Lightyear Space Ranger so you
can see at all of those those usual time
lines were going to be at least 20 to 30
minutes in line and here I'm going to be
waiting five minutes eight minutes and
six minutes I'm going to end up doing 15
things and be done for that show at
three o'clock it's amazing how much time
it saves and then I went back to my
dashboard and basically repeated the
same thing
have a pint for epcot Magic Kingdom day
to disney hollywood studios and then a
Disney animal kingdom to end it off and
of course all the information is
available here on your tablet so you can
check things off as you're going along
so all in all a fantastic tool I
recommend you checking it out it's
touring plans calm and wdw lines for the
app thank you guys for watching if you
liked this video and you want to see
more remember to subscribe to the
channel and continue to believe and if
you have any recommendations for me at
Walt Disney World let me know in the
comments below self-improvement books
are like fitness books they never work
on their own what you need is a trainer
that's Evan get the newsletter
you